malgré l'intervention du samu et des
collègues du fonctionnaire de police
le flip il déraille décède à la suite
d'une altercation devant le commissariat
de police de fort de france le 12 mars
l'autopsié du corps révélait plusieurs
hématomes et de nombreuses blessures
occasionnées par une chute durant cette
interpellation mouvementée
l' enquête confiée à la police
judiciaire fait ressortir que trois
mises en examen deux hommes une fable 27
à 30 ans avaient au préalable assisté
sur la place publique à l'interpellation
d'un homme pour usage de stupéfiants par
des hommes de la bac mécontents ces
trois individus se seraient donc rendu
au commissariat de police de
fort-de-france et aurait alors refusé
d'obtempérer aux injonctions des
fonctionnaires finalement dans une
grande confusion et les actes de
violence qui leur sont reprochés et sont
placés en garde à vue
si certains policiers sont blessés il
dira le père de famille de trois enfants
et plus de malaise il s'écroule sous les
yeux de ses collègues mis en cause dans
le décès de ce policier
les trois mis en examen devront dès
lundi matin et ce jusqu'à vendredi
s'expliquer devant la cour d'assises de
martinique